very interestingly he promotes this
album via a quran recitation let's
listen to the quran recitation which
he's picked
i've done the seven day free trial of
the korani app and exceeded all my
expectations alhamdulillah i was worried
that was an overrated product that's
what he thought until he tried it what
was the system you can build a habit
with the quran buy seven day free trial
bonuses not credit card details required
at all and you decide for yourself is it
overrated or is it underrated go to the
link in the description box below around
sisters download it and see what time it
is
salaam alaikum today better care two
brothers and sisters and dear friends
we're gonna get straight into it fresh
montana
you guys know him i don't know nothing
about abilities i just know he's some
kind of a rapper musician wherever he
may be
and subhanallah allah subhanahu wa says
mercy on us by calamities i have hardly
seen anybody come to islam or closer to
allah via blessings these are very
unique people that genuinely come close
to allah via blessing allah is giving
the blessing then i get closer to allah
very unique people but most of us
and we come to allah via calamity these
calamities that make us want to come to
him because if we then have calamities
we will think we're invincible and we
don't need allah and sadly that's the
reason why allah sends calamities
because allah says we send a smaller
calamity to divert a bigger calamity in
the hereafter and that's exactly what
happened fresh montana look what he says
in his post so in this post he says the
following they got amnesia they forgot
so that's his album that's how badly it
was affected why the album uh the album
november 12th grateful to be here to
tell my story two years ago this same
day i was in icu fighting for my life
lots of memory lots of friends lots of
hope almost i lost it
lost
and when i was down i found out all i
had was allah he picked me up and gave
me a second chance while i was trying to
bounce back they counted me out and
forgot everything we did day 730 they
got amnesia the album now very
interestingly he promotes this album via
a quran recitation let's listen to the
quran recitation which is picked
by the star when it goes down to set
[Music]
your fellow prophet has neither missed a
way nor he has deviated
[Music]
he does not speak out of his own desires
it is nothing but revelation to him
it is taught to him by the angel of
strong faculties while he listening to
this recitation if i was not a muslim
and i listened to the quran i would say
this cannot be
god almighty beautiful but let's carry
on
[Music]
the one of vigor so he stood poised
while he was on the upper horizon
[Music]
then he drew near and came down
so as he was at a distance like that of
two bows or even nearer
thus allah has revealed to his slave
what he revealed
what he sees
[Music]
the fact that french montana picked this
verse is so powerful because allah is
glorifying and affirming what the
prophet saw allah saw and those who
doubt him are in transgression because
he it is clear and it is the lord of the
heavens on the earth claiming what the
prophet sallam saw is true and he is a
true prophet and to be honest i wrap it
in a wrapping the nation inshallah that
whoever's in another whatever prophet
may be and french montana is one any
rappers when you as an icu no friends no
fans nobody
forget this this is this dunya
in the hereafter because in this dunya
you're gonna have your family and
friends which are gonna be there for you
in the hereafter mom dad brother sister
son daughter they don't know you
they don't know you not because they
hate you but that day is a severe day
and that day everyone is for himself
and that is the reason why we ask allah
to make us among the believers because
that day believers are going to want to
associate to one another yes we believed
and those who disbelieved are going to
curse each other and ask for allah to
punish them more may this be a wake-up
call for brother french montana and
inshallah he gets closer to his dean
inshallah until next time